ذكرت وكاله توتاس الروسيه ان موسكو ابلغت
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان موازعه
محطه النوويه اصيب خلاله هجوم بطائرات
مسيره وسيقوم خبراء الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه للتحقق من المعلومات بشان
استهداف الطائرات المسيره لمحطه زابورجيا
للمزيد ينضم الينا من بيولوجيا مراسلنا
حسان
مراسلتنا
ابدا معك حسان وما تقوله السلطات
الاوكرانيه بخصوص ما جرى لهذا الموزع في
محطه طبعا وفق ما ذكرته وكاله تاس الروسيه
نعم مريم حتى هذه اللحظه الجانب الاوكراني
لم يعلق على هذه المساله وعلى هذا الادعاء
بالاستهداف من هذه الجهه ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه ما زالت المنطقه المحيطه بمحطه لا
سيما من الجانب الذي نقف فيه من جانب
المنطقه الضفه اليمنى لنهر دينيبر ومدينه
او حتى مدينه نيكوكول المطله على منطقه
هذه المنطقه منطقه مغلقه لا نستطيع ان
نتوجه اليها او ان نظهر الواقع في محطه
النوويه التي تحيط بها عدد كبير من
المخاطر من اكثر من اتجاه الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث عن قصف متواصل للمنطقه
هناك وفي ذات الوقت فانه يحذر من مخاطر
تحيط بمحطه النوويه ترتبط بتفجير السد
الذي يدعي الجانب الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه هي من قامت بتفجيره يتحدثون ان
المنطقه هناك تعمل السلطات على
الاستمرار بالحفاظ على خزانات المياه
للاستمرار في تبريد المفاعلات النوويه
هناك في ذات الوقت فان
مؤسسه مؤسسه الطاقه الذريه الاوكرانيه
كانت قد اكدت ان الوضع في المحطه مازال
مستقرا حتى هذه اللحظه وما زالت تتابع
الاوضاع في محطه النوويه نحن ننتظر خلال
هذا الاسبوع زياره لرئيس الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروسي الى منطقه
زابولوجيا للقاء المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
والسلطات التي تسيطر على محطه ايضا من
الجانب الروسي هذا فيما يرتبط بهذه
المساله تحديدا وما كنا نتحدث عن منطقه
كخوفكا وعن التفجير الذي وقع بسد كخوفكا
لنتحدث ايضا عن الواقع في خرسون هناك رئيس
الاداره العسكريه
مستوى المياه انخفض الى اربعه فاصل سبعه
امتار وهو تراجع بنسبه 50 سم على الاقل
خلال اليومين الماضيين وقال انه يتوقع ان
يتراجع منسوب المياه الى متر ونصف خلال
اسبوعين القادمين الا انه ايضا حذر من ان
امطارا يمكن ان تحدث خلال الايام القادمه
وهو ما يؤخر من تراجع منسوب المياه في تلك
المنطقه وهو يتحدث بطبيعه الحال عن الضفه
اليمنى فقط من منطقه خرسانه التي غمرت
المياه فيها 35 بلده كما يقول واكثر من
3700 منزل واعمال الاجلاء ايضا ما زالت
مستمره وفاق عدد الذين تم اجزاؤهم من هناك
الفين وسبعمائه هذه التطورات المرتبطه
بنهر والسد اما خلال هذه الليله كان هناك
هجمه مكثفه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
الشمال باتجاه الجنوب كان هناك استهداف في
منطقه اوديسا قتل هناك ثلاثه اشخاص واكثر
من 26 جريحا بهجمه بالمسيرات وكذلك
بالصواريخ وكان هناك استهداف لمطار بمنطقه
بولتوفا الشمال شرقي اوكرانيا